Florida critics sense hostility from
Governor Ron DeSantis and his
conservative Crackdown in the state the
naacp's new message beware of traveling
to Florida DeSantis just days away from
announcing a bid for the White House has
been solidifying his conservative
credentials he's blocked public high
schools from offering an
African-American studies AP course
barred all grades from teaching about
gender identity and critical race Theory
and signed a ban on abortion after six
weeks more backlash from Florida's
largest private employer Disney the
company and DeSantis have feuded ever
since Disney opposed a state law critics
dubbed don't say gay just last week the
company synonymous with Florida tourism
scrapped plans for a billion dollar new
campus in the state and as for the NAACP
advisory a spokesman for DeSantis called
it a stunt